9 thomas wie ist es eigentlich zu der
idee mit den milden weiß es gekommen
gute frage eigentlich
sehr schön sehr schön
ja es war nicht mal eine die telekom
hatte die idee wie das halt so ist da
kommt so ein werbe zum zum chef und sagt
ihr passt eine idee machen was so im
internet ganz vielen leuten und dann
spielte dem was vor und mut film und da
läuft million voices 7 seconds im
hintergrund und dann sagt der chef gut
das will ich haben mit dem song und dann
fängt die serien ja wir brauchen jemand
der diese botschaft überträgt er brown
teil da müssen wir einen haben
authenzität glaubwürdigkeit und so da
gibt es dann thomas d also ruft man
anfragen sogar klar eine cherry als mit
der verdient sich dumm und dusselig
singen ihren song geht ja wohl ich muss
etwas eigenes machen muss dieses thema
übernehmen und
mit allen leuten da draußen song zu
machen das ist echt ne gute idee also
gut ab das ist wirklich eine gute idee
das finde ich geil das meistens auch nie
ich kann zwar vor leuten singen und die
können dann auch mitsingen aber dass man
also wirklich zusammen macht dem fehn
das ist ja auch mein credo jeder
verbringt er die gleiche zeit meine ist
ja nicht mehr wert und so können wir
alle zusammen unsere zeit da rein
investieren jeder wann er will
um diesen einen song zu schaffen das war
also die grundidee kamen von den
umsetzungen dann von mir endergebnis von
uns beiden es war eine schöne zeit